when is it coming out the hour the album
is February 14 is it really yes the wait
is finally over
as Justin confirms a Valentine's Day
release for his fifth studio album
changes I'm so glad you're back cuz you
took a break and this makes me so happy
and ever the crowd-pleaser the Biebs
also drops a brand new track off the
album get me featuring R&B star come on
back on Alan Justin also gets the
talk-show host with a bouquet of flowers
for her recent birthday which happens to
be his 27th appearance on her show kind
of grew up on your show yeah that I
think about yes you owe me a lot well
later in the sit down Justin explains
the very grown-up meaning behind his
latest hit yep yeah you got that
[Music]
what were you thinking of when you wrote
that yummy-yum yeah my sex life okay it
is what it is yeah married so Justin's
marriage to Haley Baldwin is a central
focus of his new YouTube docu-series
seasons tracing their love story back to
the very first meeting over a decade ago
today Justin tells Ellen he grappled
with the responsibility of marriage but
never questioned his love for his wife
and I finally was like you know I'm
gonna make the decision and follow
through with it be a husband and you
know this is what I've always wanted I'm
gonna just choose this woman and and
just do it